[Music]
in aircrews news aircrews news are you
okay I wanted to see what it felt like
to be nuts okay you got it out of your
system
I think so we're gonna take turns okay
submitted by JK all day Earth Day the
world's largest aircraft is being
designed with an amazing interior oh
[ __ ] number the largest Titanic yeah
that didn't go too well not did it but
this is an aircraft
how cool is the interior craft what
happened to the one where it's gonna
like the whole thing is like this
[ __ ] screen and then it shows
different thing rather than like the
airplane I'm a great airplane yeah like
you could see the outside yeah oh that
would be so scary
I said confusing you could have got any
deciding in my deciding waller I trying
to see no closet [ __ ] on fly right yeah
so back in 2016 they announced that the
airlander 10 which is a three hundred
and two foot long hybrid airship was
finally gonna be taking its first flight
what's that a blimp
what's an airship I need a blimp it
looks like a blimp so the Hindenburg it
looks like oh yeah you see remember the
Hindenburg the world looks like a
airplane that was stung by beam is gonna
be tight Anna it's gonna be the
Hindenburg on the Titanic all over again
yeah yeah but you know what's worse
there's no [ __ ] escape little boats
on it you're just gonna crash parachutes
I hope so if you know how to use a
parachute no [ __ ] swell it was a
15,000 feet so not as high as a regular
commercial that's still high it could
carry up to 19 passengers on three-day
expeditions most of the cabin is covered
in glass so some of the floors you can
actually see oh my god I want to put
Dave out put David in there
team that's like pretty much JK yeah
pretty much like ran out this whole
thing and all die together it's gonna be
great I [ __ ] love you guys something
looks like inside
Oh No yeah yeah yeah I'm pretty down
though are they over the Arctic yeah
wait there's only you can only fit 19
people and that big-ass thing yeah
because it's a way it down yeah yeah
that and then the actual cabin where it
is it's not that luxuries meant for luck
sure sure in the sky there's it saying
you can go for a three-day cruise so
it's like a luxury ship in this in the
air I'm sexy why would I want to do that
cuz I want to get out and like sightsee
you know I know maybe it lands oh maybe
one your sightseeing underneath the
thing you want to stay in the area like
this would be perfect for like the Grand
Canyon or like a rainforest or like not
places or go shopping it's like it's
like it's like Google Maps but isn't
gonna be like this like you look at the
Grand Canyon you're like here's the bank
you guys it's really slow you know
reminds me of it reminds me of um in the
switch the Mario you know what's it
called the Mario Mario Odyssey Odyssey
yeah the way he travels and that ship
thing it looks like that yeah so the
maximum speed that it reaches is about
91 miles per hour
I've been nosing oh that's really slow
super slow like the air but I can slow
as [ __ ] it's not an airplane okay
she's laughing throwing the things I
picture like 400 miles an hour you know
I'm like the Airbus a380s
cruising speed is 560 miles per hour
oh this one's baleen I mean so it's
really slow so it's meant to be like a
luxurious it's as fast as a car speeding
on the highway
yeah so just it's hovering like a
helicopter Connors days
three days like it's it's like it's not
space like this I would do it [ __ ] this
looks gorgeous let me shoot some
[ __ ]
okay but like if you're a Harris Aileen
pictures no okay so when you're
parasailing yeah like really funny for
like the first minute yeah and then you
kind of get bored but there's other [ __ ]
to do right where do you sleep
that bedrooms that's actually nineteen
people
ah there's other [ __ ] to do watching
that [ __ ] thick so this is built in the
UK my dog and it has a nickname decay oh
the flying bomb get the point boom there
you go yeah yeah oh you know be cool if
they have stations where you could just
lay down like you're snorkeling and then
you just lay down and then you can see
everything in here I'm getting the
binoculars so you could zoom in like
Google Earth I'm getting two places and
a giant thing with less people and it
goes a lot slower I think they want you
to enjoy the actual travel part of it
well this wasn't for you that you like
you don't want airplanes when you're
flying yeah this isn't meant to be a
flight yeah it's like if I could take it
a train no I know but even as a viewer
like when I'm flying over the mountains
in an airplane it feels pretty slow even
though it's going we're super fast
because you're so high you can't see
[ __ ] okay you are so high up yeah he's a
grade 91 miles per hour it's like okay
I've seen this cliff for like the past
hour and a half
Jesus over this cliff strippers a bishop
result consider it I mean you could hire
them and I don't know if I could do
three days of strippers why'd you to
parachute off after like Kapow
you bet just need to get out of school I
just have fun really trying to find the
prettiest one is throw money at him Wow
there are humans to Jeana you can't
throw it my what they love the money so
it's okay don't throw it she's pretty
good at making it rain yeah she taught
Julia pass it on she taught me how to
play craps I teach Julia had thrown
money on strippers we gotta go back to
Vegas again first they have a casino
oh yeah Venice without strippers in
Atlantis they probably do their
international dude sure this first shows
you because I only like buying lap
dances for people cuz I got one and I
was like not fun yeah I'm not 18 anymore
just get one no she didn't walk not mmm
she she got one for me or she'd pick one
for me yeah there's not one really hot
one that we never saw her he got she was
so pretty Vall the one oh yeah [ __ ] yeah
she pull her titties on breeze nipple
like that
she took off hers and then briefs and in
she went she took her did II thought
they she was pulling her titties on my
gentleman her bra her bra her bra now be
fine if she took her titties on this is
a [ __ ] like anatomy strip showed [ __ ]
like she's ripping off her skin yeah oh
that's nasty they know how much is gonna
be oh no not yet you can't even join a
waiting list for tickets yet but so they
are saying here though that it's only
completed six successful test flights so
far out of 12 and so they're saying that
it needs to complete 200 incident three
hours in the sky because it did have a
crash landing in August of 2016 November
2017 it deflated before takeoff
yes is not really selling it for me
they're testing it though I mean that's
a work out the kinks get back to me in
20 years so they're not selling tickets
yours yeah would you ever ride the
Goodyear blimp that goes around launch
right here I like for put like you can
buy tickets yeah I want to the meetings
go that I wanted to write a hot-air
balloon until I read about all of the
hot air balloon accidents and then I was
like gonna have an accident anywhere
anything you know but this is like you
can't control it once the left the wind
like gust comes along it like blows the
balloon into a thing and then you get it
like it's your time to go it's your time
to go I don't want to die that way it's
into invite-only oh I've been seeing it
since I was a child because the place
that they launch from is near mine how
do you have a dinner in there or
something
Wow oh good ear invite us yeah well I
don't want to go but invite them are you
afraid of heights no more than the blimp
I don't I don't really trust the blimp
just sounds boring as [ __ ] and it sounds
boring guys I'm boring why because it's
slow sometimes slow things are fun and
also it's just a lot of gas in there I
could have known alright but if you had
a bicycle that could fly would you cuz I
would hmm why does that slow I want to
do a jetpack so cool cuz you're in
charge of it okay yeah if you all the
air around you but what if the bicycle
was that like lame ass lake one that you
[ __ ] ride like a big one no no that's
too much work good sell though what is
that big lame one yeah I want that one I
always hear like couples battling bad
[ __ ] it looks like they're paddling
their [ __ ] life away I know like
barely move it's barely movie party now
oh really yeah that leads to dump bodies
there and now it's like a hipster
paradise the world has changed Echo Park
oh yes yeah for a video those big-ass
[ __ ] baby yeah nice to be cholo
no one went there scary gentrified yeah
it's crazy
well maybe the cholos just grew up and
they're like me maybe we got to invest
in our future you know what I'm thinking
like gang bang is not a pretty good idea
there's no longevity but I'm like really
into this slow drip coffee so like maybe
we already have that do you just got a
grown-up beer and love your writing and
a man bud
[Music]